good to see you gang the boys are
planning the ru garbage 2024 tour and we
want to know where you want us to come
yeah so click the link in the
description let us know what cities you
want us to come to we're coming to all
the ones we've been to before and we're
adding a bunch new ones we just need to
know where to go so click the link let
us know and we'll see you out there gang
staying at your house welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite
podcast this is R you garbage oh yeah
it's that little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find it
if they group to be classy yeah if
they're just a big old piece of trash
trash trash TR I'm your host H fley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
out back here at toies in the new
edition she's out running some errands
she had to stop at the bank she had to
see your parole officer hit the plug
okay come back all right my co-host is
coming at you unfortunately right next
to me he is the CEO of Ru garbage he's
International businessman he is the
gummy bear bandit give it up for KJ
Kevin James Ryan with his nice jacket on
what's up guys it's a shirt thanks for
tuning in everybody we love you first of
all please make sure you rate youw
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
TR cooking baby and obviously the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com
rarb gang it's a party over there yes it
is is and having a nice quick shout out
to our producer extraordinary the old
magic man makes us all look good works
the ones the twos the threes and the
fours he crosses the t's and he dos the
eyes give it up for T-Bone mccuins Toby
McMullan ladies and gentlemen what up
boys we have an absolute Legend yes we
Ed yes we do a killer amongst Killers
this guy gang the long hair ain't lying
we couldn't be more excited of our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guest back with us again today it's his
first time here at toies in a new
edition we love him you love them he is
the host of you know what dude he is the
host of bone to pick co-host on the
bonfire and the rags got to check out
give it up for Robert Kelly everybody a
lot of podcast a lot ofc I mean you guys
are so happy one of yours hit you ain't
lying sweetheart I got I'm still rolling
the [__] dice I saw you zipping
around the West Village the other night
in that uh in that premium SUV what are
you talking about oh yeah that was so
funny I what are you whipping around I
got Lexis got Lexi little little highb
Lex zipping around okay that's a jacket
by the way sure I'll it no I saw him on
the on the street in the bike laye and I
just zipped up like I was going to hit
him just to see what type of guy he is
you know what I mean what was his
reaction cuz if he's like oh my God oh
my God you know some people oh he got
down to a threo blue 42 thought it was
an Uber I jumped in the back seat he who
the kid in front of whoever that was
pushed him out of the way and he went
what the [__] watch out watch out what
the [__] and I was like exactly who I
thought F he was he he saved the life
and stepped in front can't park that
here buddy you told me you were out of
town and I see you zipping
around love a good Li uno momento that's
Spanish uh thanks is is Babel a
sponsor not yet but they could be no
dude I was that was Tuesday yeah I said
hey can you can you come in Thursday
you're like now I'm going to be out of
town leaving to the next morning at 5:
in the morning I told you I'm jumping on
a plane where Tamp Tampa love a nice
Tampa I did a private event at a cigar
lounge Corona cigar okay and it was uh
for
me your dream game dud I'm looking out
get paid to smoke sticks me and Mike
Calton Mike Calton was uh who's my
number one best friend and uh you've
done him you know C he's the best so I
go dude come down and he's done stand up
with before he'll go up and do 10
minutes [__] off blah blah blah my
crowd's his crowd down there his crowd's
my crowd his Turf down there but he goes
up the king of Tampa the king of Tampa
king of Florida Florida so he goes up
and
uh and he's just winging it and it's
it's like but this is his crowd but then
there's these cigar people which is a
different world man watching your buddy
bomb there Ain too many things better
like great you know what's better than
that making your buddy bomb have you
ever done that no but I know you animals
used to do it to each other back in the
day at the seller me and Keith me and
Keith did it to Voss Voss had follow
Nicki Glazer okay Nikki Glazer killing
and it's all mostly young girls I mean
murdering with these jokes and Voss is
going up we know that [__] old cot's
gonna sit try to bring back the energy
to his thing I went on one side he went
on the other keth went on this side I
went on that side and every joke he did
we went oh I would have [__] killed
you next the whole crowd five minutes in
a they all just got on board dude the
whole crowd everything he said and then
at one point the girl looked up at me
and Liz she why would he talk like
this took a hot one um one of that so
you're doing a little traveling you're
down in Tampa where does a where do
where does a guy like Bobby like to stay
you're a hotel man I would assume an
Airbnb guy yeah I'm no no no no no
nothing I can't do an Airbnb MH I'm with
you we were a big Airbnb team but we're
off now back to hotels and how's your
hotel
etiquette I like alls I need in a hotel
I need a little tiny G mhm I don't need
room service I don't need that okay I'm
not a snob like that I a little gym I
need a little coffee free breakfast you
like a free breakfast I'm all right with
that but I'm not going to [__] with it
really I know what it's about huh I know
I I used to but now i' I'd rather just
go somewhere and get breakfast okay I
don't feel like waiting in a line man
you feel like I do love a a hotel
breakfast but you don't feel your best
waiting behind a [__] like three
mouth breathers for the [__] for the
waffle just a family of fat six uhhuh
yeah it's bad dude for a single serving
of yl oh and there yeah are you guys
bringing more bacon and a green banana
yeah and they're touching every
banana and then they and then you see
them in their bag is full of yogurts and
milks and it's like all right relax you
[__] it's fre [__] grocery shopping
at the [__] days in yeah I I'm all
right but I'm not a snob like that I
like an I flat flat this how old I am I
got to the point where I told my agent I
go listen I'm not staying in hotels with
square
TVs I don't want to box is that is that
on the website how do they know that I
used to I used to stay at hotels and it
had like a square the big guy yeah you
guys you guys you remember that I
remember that yeah so yeah I I was like
dude enough I want a flat screen TV I
want flat I want a thin TV if it doesn't
have a thin TV I'm not [__] staying
cuz those those Square TV rooms it's
rough real primadana over
here I'm not getting up to change the
channels no more it better have a remote
[Laughter]
I need a record player no more this atra
[__] hen Youngman I'm I'm first
floor near the elevator too oh what
first floor dude I don't want to I don't
ground floor I hate having to get into a
[__] elevator Tru driver that's crazy
that's the first guy that gets got dude
get got then I'm actually the first guy
to get away I hear the [__] going on I'm
out that emergency doors never open what
are you talking about you're on the
[__] fifth floor down the end of the
hallway you got nowhere to go the first
floor first floor bang man you're
looking for trouble down there sleeps
with the door open I love it why welcome
Intruders I leave my I leave my curtain
open I love it I love when people pull
up in their car and I'm just staring
right at them and I wave my got the flat
tvs get your ass in here the first floor
of a hotel first floor of the hotel you
go and check in and say Hey I want a
room on the first floor yeah I like the
first floor by the elevator too too I
don't you hear it dinging and stuff and
by the way that's indicative of where
you're staying that they have rooms on
the first floor most hotels don't Hiatt
has first floor and I'll take a handicap
room I don't like though I don't like
walking into the shower like that it's
too creep I love it uhuh I need you've
never been fat fat I there was a time
where like I had to wash myself off like
a baby elephant I had to get that hose
try to put a leg up get underneath dude
that stupid tub standing there with my
little fees in then the curtain hits the
side [__] I like walking in I like a
ballerina bar in there sit down they
have a little flapping bench feel like
I'm in a hospital dude I can't do it
yeah I love that I love the wand do you
use that chair to get into the
pool Marco going around will you dip in
the pool if there's a pool uh 100% okay
bring your trunks hop in the hot tub I
always bring trunks I'll hop into the
hot tub I'll go [__] blow an old guy
in the sauna whatever they got so I used
those hotels up man okay yeah one of the
best times I've ever had was in Kansas
City at a hotel where the pool was
inside and then went outside who and it
went outside it was a snowstorm uh I was
outside heated pool snow coming down
sick and I was just sitting there with
my little bald head coming out it was
great I remember that for the rest of my
life dude on the road you really we
we'll we'll hop in the pool and you'll
really get some nice just relaxing
moments pre just in there floating with
your other fat friend in a hot tub it's
all right it's the best I I ha Comics
that don't use the amenities uhuh like I
used to go on the road with Comics like
I remember Dane would never use the
amenities you know I'd wake up early I'd
go down and get the coffee [__] yeah dud
I hang out in that little like Lobby
like Lobby restaurant I'm in there I got
coffee I sit on the chairs by the
elevator use those got a little Journal
time little hey today was a good day
ding someone comes out say hello have a
good day I use it all man they call
doing it all baby if like that if you
sit in if you if you go down to the hot
tub at the hotel and there's somebody
else in there will you hey how you doing
will you chat them up a little bit well
you know what or will you give them
their space and be like I'm GNA hop in
the pool and then when they get out I'll
get in the hot tub I well it depends
I'll usually get in the hot tub and I
and I I'll be like how you doing I'll
say hi you need the initial hi just to
let you know I'm not here I'm not here
to I'm not here to suck Market I'm not
sucking I'm not here to get my dick
sucked I'm not sucking your dick doing
but it feels like that though when did
you and another guy in the hot tub like
someone's got to make a move here not
when you do like I I lay on the Boston a
little hey what's up how are you you
what I mean so he knows I'm not going to
suck your dick sure you know what I mean
and then I'll C your game last night H I
get my corner and then I shut my eyes
and then you do what you do I got to
really phase you out okay cuz if you
start talking to me in the hot tub I
don't want that I don't want to have a
conversation in a hot tub dude we were
somewhere in Miami remember that whole
family surrounded you there was like K
jumping on his back was wild I was in
the pool I'm like dude I he's like come
over here I not coming in and I would
never like would you let the kid get
into a hot tub with a grown man that
know yeah no the parents weren't in
there the parents were over in the seats
and these two kids Rug Rats come over
here's what happens when you have more
than one k had his hands above the water
just like I'm not doing anything you're
almost hoping that he would play with
them sure a little bit like yeah cuz I
have a kid and it's like there's a
certain point where you're like [__] I
just I don't wna have to go in the pool
I don't want to have to yeah I was
chilling what the [__] a kid doing in
a goddamn hot tub
anyway a long day what do you want him
to pee go swimming you want him to pee
in the pool yeah pee in the pool hot tub
is just pissed by the way of course it's
just hot P's not first thing I do when I
get in there right away what yeah
biologically it makes you pee we were on
a cruise uh recently and my kid was in
the pool last day of the cruise probably
maybe four four 3 four hours left of the
pool time before they have to close it
down right and my kid uh we hit a wave
and the water came down right in his
mouth this kid puked dude he puked whole
starboard side Jesus they came out with
hazmat suits they had to shut the
[__] pool down because it was
everywhere he shut he shut the pool down
on the cruise the last night oh my God
Bobby and his kid on a singles cruise
coming up the works for everybody hey
[__] knock it off there's chicks out
here [__] face paint and [__]
Mickey ears
that was a that was right before birs
Cruise cuz I think I remember seeing
that and that was a social cruise that
you weren't working you just went on a
cruise you're a cruise guy the whole fam
went I'm not a cruise guy I tried the
cruise guy this was was this the first
time you is the cruise he's a cruise
person okay and he said I invited him up
for Thanksgiving M cuz we spend like
every other Thanksgiving together and he
was like well we're going on a cruise
why don't you go on the cruise wait hold
on side question where does he stay when
he comes up does he get a hoteles he
stay with you yeah Hotel would you let
him stay with you 100% but he's not
going to fit he stay in a hotel up by
you or a hotel in the city he stays in
the city okay he stays in the city we
gent we've spent we went we went uh to
uh Pigeon Forge one year with him you
drop that like we were going to know
what that was Pigeon Forge Tennessee you
know where all the kids died that war
what the [__] where the where the mind
collaps you know that restaurant where
they do the fox meat up there all right
I'll tell you if you don't know Pigeon
Forge Pigeon Forge it's it's the redneck
lost Vegas I'm listening it's the
redneck Las Vegas if you I mean you go
down there they have it's literally like
they have the Titanic they have all this
[__] they have roller coasters all this
crazy [__] Pigeon Forge popped up right
away it's the home of Dollywood is where
Dollywood we went to Dollywood but you
can rent these cabins in the woods the
smoke mountains with Dolly Parra for
[__] nothing you rent these big
houses and he him and his brother rented
a house and we we drove down from here
and spent like a week down in Pigeon
Forge with them and it was it's crazy
they change the name of that nothing
good starts with pigeon dude my hometown
that's rough my hometown uh Bluebell was
originally named pigeon Town pigeon Town
yeah they a big sign when you when you
when you pull in a lot of pigeons the
mayor the mayor was a pigeon actually
the mayor was a pig yeah two terms a but
got inded so he said to me he goes
listen why don't you come down I was
like okay let me ask Dawn cuz I know my
wife's going to go [__] no she's
gonna she's a nickel Chaser she's not
going to spend the money nickel Chaser
what are you from the
20s pigeon tow nickel Chaser yeah she's
tight with the cash he what do you give
me the high hat you give me the high hat
so I I know she's gonna say no
immedately I go yeah let me ask Don
think I'm go don want to go on a cruise
for Thanksgiving she's going to go uh no
we're not going on to cruise cuz she
loves we love she cooks she cooks
everything so we usually have
Thanksgiving at the house we invite any
comic stragglers over wait you were it
was a the Thanksgiving was a c was you
would spent on a cruise it's
Thanksgiving
Cruise pigeon for that's [__] nuts
there's no way my wife's gonna say yes
though there's no I'm gonna go yes she's
gonna go no I went D you to cruise for
the CST for Thanksgiving she goes yeah
that sounds fun and I went huh did you
have a thank did you eat Thanksgiving
this wasn't this Cru worst Thanksgiving
I've ever had yeah this was this Cru
right cuz yeah it had to be no I thought
you this Thanksgiving you went on a
cruise yeah I'm not lying to you Bobby
that's [__] insane dude it was the
did you did they at least make a
Thanksgiving dinner that you can eat at
the buffet or you eat macaroni and
cheese and [__] like you have a
Thanksgiving dinner and it was the worst
Thanksgiving dinner of of course it was
terrible it was terrible my wife cooks
from the ground up third generation
stuffing
like I have her made I have her make I
have third that means her pigeon meat
secret ingredients her [__] Grand
great great grandmother passed it on to
the grandmother passed it on to the now
it's her okay okay tried and true it is
dud I have her make it in the middle of
the Year I'll pregame this [__]
just to have okay say keep her skills up
I must one of the one of a fight I got
with Dame one time we did Thanksgiving
at his house my wife's cook
from she's cooking everything at his
place at his place and he's like I'm
going to get a sto top I was like what I
go my wife's cooking her third
generation stuffing she's like yeah but
we like I go it's not happening you're
not you're not [__] you have in my
wife stuffing no [__] you can't you
can't I'm not letting you have a box of
stuffing man it's the greatest the
greatest meal ever it's one of the I
mean her cooking I'm with that I mean
it's the greatest and I went from that
to a cruise Thanksgiving Cru
Thanksgiving the stuffing had the
consistency of mashed potatoes dude if
you're eating gravy in a bathing suit
that is a tough look yeah dud imagine
imagine you a turkey leg and then
getting on a water slide that's [__]
nut the food on Bird's Cruise was
fantastic was not a good what that the
cruise we went on wasn't a great Cruise
they had no water slide they had a pool
that my kid threw up in that was it jesz
that was it the food was not that good
it was kind of terrible it was terrible
man also the food on birds Cruise was
good but we were also drunk most of the
time I fantastic Soup To Nuts everything
breakfast lunch dinner chicken fingers
are fantastic Thanksgiving dinner that's
that's I mean that's what I'm saying it
was yeah you're talk you're talking uh
you're talking Rando food I mean we were
getting the VIP food we were we weren't
you know we could go to the buffet me to
me me and Big Jay hit the buffet one
time man after losing like losing our
asses at the blackjack table he's like
you want to go get hamburgers I'm like
yes I do we sat down for like 3 hours
and just crushed them off it I did that
on the Joker's cruise I remember getting
out of the elevator at the Joker the
same ship yeah same ship okay so we got
out and there was four huge women with
two plates each it was pizza with mac
and cheese on top of the pizza okay on
both plates yeah at 2:30 in the morning
yes and then we went we went into the
buffet and these two other fatties drove
their Larks into the chairs to move them
didn't move the chairs used the [__]
you hear and then they just put their
[__] food ate off their their
wheelchairs he got a bulldozer on the
front just dumps potatoes
got got to love that I do respect uh the
Comfort level of people on a cruise was
very reassuring of like people of like
all shapes and sizes going
this there's no self-conscious I got
this is my kind of [__] place this
Cruise was an old people Cruise though
it was not a good Cruise was it the
three of in a room or did you get the
kid his own room no what he [__] 10
what you out of your mind [__] get him
his own room SP five grand on this
[__] kid you out your mind sleeping
right in the he had a couch okay yeah
I'm not rolling like
that no I had he we had one room for all
of us but it was a big room it was like
a junior whatever sweet okay it was fine
first
floor I got to be able to go I got to
stick and move Bob's down in the boil
room I take it man K but suck about
tushi shout out to tushi dang you want
to feel like a fancy European type huh
walking around with a cafe latte I can
have my cafe latte with a nice Crystal
Clean
butthole it's time to Chuck the toilet
paper and get yourself a bedet from
tushy uhhuh tushi bedet are easy to set
up on any toilet takes about 10 minutes
to get it all set up easy peasy next
thing you know you're pooping away
sliding that be holees whistling baby
clean as a whistle uh yeah it's one of
those things you don't know what it is
until you give it a shot and you go it's
a game Chang changes the way you looked
at your whole entire life up to this
point you got a shower for weeks I put a
little on I use it on my armpits clean
up not only will you use 75% less toilet
Pap toilet paper on average the tshi
Beday stays clean and hygienic and it's
patented self-cleaning smart spray uh
the nozzle self cleans before and before
and after each use automatically in the
big day uh stays just as clean as your
cheeks and with a 30-day hassle-free
return and a 12-month warranty it's
risk-free baby so here's the turkey uh
get that get that fresh out of the
shower feeling at hellotushy.com for a
limited time our listeners will get 10%
off your entire order when you use the
code garbage at checkout that's 10% off
your first order at hello tushi h l l t
y.com with promo code garbage it's time
to back that ass up with
confidence shake it shake what your mama
gave you Kevin talk about mint mobile
mint mobile gang they say a recent study
has come out saying that it takes 30
days to break your New Year's resolution
only took me tooo I'm ahead of the curve
kids a genius over here gang do yourself
a favor get over to mmobile it is a New
Year's resolution that you don't have to
break if saving money is that resolution
$15 a month starting plans over there
you know why cuz there's no brick and
mortar it's all done online they pass
the savings right onto you shout out to
Mr Ryan Reynolds good look again yeah uh
for limited time wild those plans for
mmobile are just 15 bucks a month when
you buy a three-month plan we're talking
unlimited talks Text data for 15 bucks a
month 2G what's the network uh 5G 2G
what is it the 90s I'm talking 5G this
is handmade quality [__] we're talking
about uh my wife's been using uh mmobile
for years way before they were sponsored
way before this podcast ever existed we
were a mmobile family it's fantastic you
get to keep your phone your phone number
and all your contacts the only thing
that changes is your bill all plans come
with unlimited talk deex highpe data
delivered on a nation's largest 5
network uh you got nothing to lose but a
ton of money and you save that I mean to
get this new customer offer uh and your
new three-month Unlimited Wireless plan
for just 15 bucks a month go to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage cut your wireless
build at 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com garbage additional taxes
fees and restrictions apply see me see
mintmobile for details did you T did you
tip the cleaning and a hotel what do you
leave for the hotel for the cleaning St
20s 20 bucks off after a week 20 bucks
when I check in 20 bucks when I leave 20
bucks when you check in what do you mean
cuz we usually check in before 3 cuz we
get in you know what I mean and they
always say our room isn't ready room
isn't ready it happens to me so much I
have to not be stressed when I do this
[__] I the same way I can't I can't I've
been doing it for so long I can't deal
with I have clear I have TSA I have
Global one I have the lounge I have the
all the credit like being I don't want
to I I can't have anybody [__] with me
because I'll I'll just quit I'll just be
out right there with you Bobby living on
the edge yeah man and when you get to
the hotel if I walk in like your room
will be ready and it's 11:30 your room
will be to three CU technically that's
what you sign up for sure if you walk in
give the chick a double Berry to the the
double Berry what the [__] hey go buy
yourself some pigeon meat uh what the
[__] snippy Laro over a double Berry
you're douber how you doing I'm lucky
Bobby Kelly I'm here to check in here's
the saw Buck HS pulls it out of her ear
there you go give me something down in
the basement well next to the laundry
room on the slot machines a 20 was a
double Berry two berries oh okay that
makes
sense that's real Cruise talk right
there wait so you're not tipping the
cleaning staff you're you're greasing
the the the the front the the the the
the front desk the front desk person
front desk people make no money they
have to stand they cannot sit so you
grease them so when you walk and they
they don't give a [__] they're told you
know not to give certain people room
that room's ready I'm walking they got
an open room there's always a room sure
there's always a room that's great
always a [__] room and if I walk in I
go listen I go here that I go I'm
checking in blah and they're like well
we don't and as soon as I hear the well
I go hey this is for you thanks just
thanks for trying to get me a room right
now I appreciate it I don't say get me
one you can't force you say do what you
can whatever you I get it but you know
I'm just a little tired and then they go
okay and you see them you see the
[__] Mouse just go like this cuz they
were over here and the you ain't getting
a [__] room Mouse and then they start
doing that step to the next computer
they go like this and they go like that
like this one wasn't even on sorry and
then you all right I can put you on the
bang now what happens you grease him to
20 so sorry nothing he calls a scene
obviously strangle I get that money back
and hang them upside down out a [__]
window no it never happens okay room
there is all room so then when you leave
if you stay one night Chris 20 on the
dresser 20 on the dresser who love that
unless I buy something that I don't want
yeah like a pair of shoes or something
I'll just leave those oh you'll leave
them a gift I've left them gifts are you
kidding me I bought like a jack a
shirt no no I'm kidding I always leave a
20 yeah he half a bag of Doritos in
there for you double XL Tommy Bahama
there's a half a taco salad taco salad
and some Gatorade zero hey you can watch
the rest of Oppenheimer if you want with
it he got 23 hours left better make it
quick yeah I leave [__] in the hotel all
the time all right no I always a 20 man
you know Colin Quinn taught me that
respect that Colin was like he always
every time I used to open for him all
the time and we'd go on the road and
he'd always leave a 20 so just boom and
we'd leave like that night cuz he
doesn't even like to stay if you're if
if you can drive home bang just leave a
20 on the table Yeah man I really
respect that that's fantastic leav a
hotel in the middle of the night but
here's the deal can I just say something
if I'm there for one day or five days
it's a it's a 20 it's a double it's just
a 20 no yeah anything yes no I agree
with because that averages out to four
five like five bucks a night or whatever
more yeah whatever it is but I'm most
people don't live [__] that's crazy they
don't live lugat there's nothing I've
been jammed up where I didn't have cash
and like we're run it's like we got to
get in the car we got to run but uh
typically there been there's been times
I'm going to admit that too once in a
while I'll have to take off and if she's
a [__] sure how would you what
interaction would you have with her um
or them I've had them are you getting
the room cleaned up every day no never
no but if they come in if they knock on
the door and that I don't no you don't
come in you put your privacy on the
thing all the whole time yeah you don't
come in love that you can't see what's
going on I don't want you to smell it I
don't want you to come in and have to I
don't want to I I I kind of I get a i
ferment the room I season it and I want
that to beans yeah like a humidor I
season the humidor and I want that to be
my room the thing but I don't smoke or
anything like I know Comics that light
up you guys light you smoke light what
are we Aerosmith smoking in the hotel
throw my Square TV out the window you
don't know people smoke in the hotel I
don't yeah dude I know Comics that just
L uped weed cigarettes weed I kind of I
I mean we how how it's worse than a
cigarette weed now smells forever nah I
disagree a little bit you're not wrong
it's gotten worse for sure it's the when
I smoked weed back in the day yeah it
was gone it didn't smell MH but now I
mean I can smell certain people will
come to my house my house will smell no
you're not wrong like weed it's it's
terrible they need to fix it they made
weed weed more potent which I'm fine
with I think that's great but now fix
the stupid gentically engineer the smell
yeah you can't why couldn't you do
something it's even walking around New
York City it's Pleasant roast beef
meatballs you know what's crazy when you
can smell it from
I I become a drug addict rotisserie
chicken weed maybe a food addict and a
drug addict they made weed smell like
[__] meatballs that's what they
should be doing yeah it smells smells
like a beef and beer all the time I know
guys that have so much money they just
take the 250 hit sure take the hit
that's a balls I can see that yeah all
right cool I'll pay the money they pay
an extra 250 justers in there just a rip
in the room I like going down doing the
doing the ritual go down out in the
lobby go outside we're also in
we don't hang out that often at the
we're usually one and done or maybe two
nights at Max I get the when you go to
certain placees like Vegas will have a
smoking floor I don't like I don't like
smoking in the room M Mohan son has
smoking floor too yeah I don't like that
that just smells like losing as a as a
guy who man I did it dude imagine losing
all your money going back to a smoking
room we were in the Golden Nugget at the
for skankfest and you could tell walking
down the hallway it's like oh man people
used to rip heaters and he yeah it's
just in the W in the grain of the wood
the carpet in the wallpaper I did it in
Rio when I did the seller in Rio I got a
smoking floor smoking room and uh one of
the lonliest things I've ever done I lit
up a cigar like a 2hour cigar by myself
people on that floor I was just sitting
I could see my reflection in the in the
in the glass I was just I'm like this
stinks like this is the Loneliest thing
of D yeah you really should be watching
people
bang something sitting in front of a
two-way
mirror watching the
show
um I got one before we get into the
patreon questions we were we were
talking about this this week who is the
most famous person you met before you
started doing comedy like as a kid was
there a local celebrity a news anchor an
actor somehow some
musician um who was like somebody that
like lingered around of like I met so
and so one
time like met them or or was in the same
area so well what was the area you
didn't have to have dinner with them but
it's got to be more than that oh my God
go on a cruise for Thanksgiving with
them well I I mean I did a um there's
two times I did a um one time I was
after an Aros Smith concert okay uh the
angel remember Angel remember that one
the video I'm in that video by the way
are you I'm in the stance in the video
Yeah was alive making out with a chick
making out with Bonnie this chick Bonnie
pelli from [__] Medford we were at
the concert I go the camera's coming and
we just started so we get in the you you
can see me I think a little bit I don't
know if it's me
but Bonnie pelli for Medford but we went
smoking hot um sounds it we uh we went
uh backstage and we got the we got to
meet Aros Smith how'd you get backstage
passes I had my friend he blew the sound
guy my friend was a musician from
Berkeley and he got this [__] so okay
we're backstage in this line to to to
say hi and I remember I just saw these
Aros Smith posters on the wall so I just
went [__] it and I grabbed one and all
of a sudden people just went and grabbed
them all and then uh I knew Steve was in
the program uh AA and not to out him but
he's already outed himself and um
Stephen Tyler is Steve he's he knows him
so he calls him Steve yeah well supposed
to be anonymous well he's he's talking
about it so you know what I mean he's
out so it's me and
Steve so he Tred to get real father with
him how you holding up you all right my
real dad's name is Steve hi Dad wherever
you are haven't seen you in a long time
time give us a call on Facebook would
you give us a call you have a grandson
he's 10 um it's stepen Tyler he has your
Bump
chin so uh I just leaned over and I I I
went uh hey Steve Bill W says hi which
is the founder of yeah friend of Bill
W's friend of Bill W's and he literally
just went hey and he [__] lost it he
was like all right all right I was like
what's up man he's like all right Bill W
yeah and he that was it and then I doing
a line of
coke don't don't tell him you [__] n
you rat you see Bill you keep your mouth
shut put those posters back I uh we I
got up to the line I thought it but he
was just like hey what's up sign sign
sign get the [__] out sure that was it I
thought I'd have a little more
interaction but that was my interaction
and then the other
one um was
uh um she's I guess she's famous I Ela
duchu who was the of course daughter in
True Lies yeah famous actor yeah she was
in
Banshee bans you didn't see Banshee the
TV show Banshee no come on guys what
year did it come out it's [__] recent
okay bansi it's the greatest
show it's so good you haven't seen
Banshee God damn it you guys are really
successful oh yes Eliza duu yes yes yes
okay she SM SM yeah well how'd you meet
her well she my acting teacher was
putting together it's a reading you this
couldn't be before you were famous what
are you talking about this is before I
was famous this was just when I was like
taking acting class and [__] this is
back in Boston you were a grown man no I
was a kid I was like 20s something okay
was like 20s something and she was a kid
at that time she was just in True Lies
and she was actually probably like teens
late teens right and uh what was it uh
wallberg was supposed to do the reading
it's a reading so they had movie script
they're going to read it they read it in
front of a live audience but they did it
at mamin which is uh you know which is
uh Aros Smith's bar on lown street right
near alligator Gorge this famous bar I
like details guys and but you say to me
like we grew up together uh mamin so you
sure
yeah you don't know [__] mamin the
song play with the cheesecake you don't
know Aros Smith songs I don't know mamin
no you ever heard that song the hits
Bobby we're not listening to bsides on
an a track in the back of some van
loveing an elevator bro dude that's not
a hit that's no that's dream on that's a
hit kilin what's it called mamin like
mamin mamin yeah
M wait so it was at this place anyways
so they had this reading at this place
and um took an acting class at a bar no
no no
they had the reading in the bar you know
what I mean I apologize sounds like a
real studious CL hey guys are having a
reading it's half price
Shooters unless you're a friend of Bill
W
B so doing a oneman show at potbellies y
Marky Mark's down at ramkin we got to go
no not Marky Mark who's the other one
the other he's on Blue BL Don so Donnie
wall couldn't even get
March this play stinks Bobby Donnie
wallberg holy [__] that's ncky
Walberg to Bill W's no but this is this
is uh 6 cents air time I like right
either right before it or right after it
you remember that movie a lot of
critical Acclaim Smith's cousin came
down so now I remember when Donnie
Wahlberg did that it was a huge deal CU
he was so good and nobody knew it was
him right so he's so they're doing this
big reading for this movie my teacher's
directing it it's a big deal in Boston
you know and but hold on just to go back
what's the movie I don't [__] know
they're just doing a reading of a movie
yeah a lot of times when they write a
script they'll have a reading about to
be made so it's like they were reading
Top Gun or something like you never did
a reading yes I've done a reading I I I
just didn't understand know yeah you
know you're a [__] thesbian like me
next to Lucy Lou yeah so I I did not
Lucy Lou Megan Lou her
sister was before the burger Fame it was
a Ben's pizza I did one with
uh
what the [__] is her name uh from uh
from uh my cousin
Vinnie Merc to I did want mer to godamn
man she's she's hot she's something else
beautiful and
talented so I guess this is be this is
right when I'm coming up in Boston I'm
I'm not I'm still going to [__]
coming up in Boston you taking I take
this thing he Donnie bailes out last
minute like the day of and it's with
Eliza and a bunch of
actors young they have this one little
young black kid he's he's really
supposed to be talented he's on the rise
my teacher goes you got to fill it you
got to help me out you got to do this so
I'm like [__] you got to read the script
so I got to read it on the Fly I got
dyslexia I'm [__] stupid I I can't I
got to read in front of 200 people
confidence problem yeah I mean it's bad
you know what I mean when I learn lines
I got to [__] spaghetti read for
hours he pulls you out of the class
you're going to be up there on stage
reading say listen I need you to do this
tonight okay so I got to go in I'm
sitting there they mic us up we're miked
live audience they're reading the script
the the writer there my teachers there
it's a big shot for a young young
there's famous local celebrities in the
crowd I think there was a couple Red
Soxs there it was Philly
fanatic Fisk Fisk was there Jim Rice was
in the crowd
no f
at a table read he was doing
this so there I am in front of Big Poppy
so you know big poy so I don't know any
of this [__] so I'm doing it and you
know I I gotta I'm this tough guy drug
addict or pimp or whatever the [__] I
was and this little kid I gotta read a
lot of my lines with this kid and uh so
I I don't know the [__] script I'm
kind of winging it where I can and
there's one time I'm like it must be um
uh it must be tough for you but the line
is must be tough for you in school okay
I said must be tough for you kid and he
go he was just staring at me dead air
hundreds of people I go must be tough
for you
kid nothing I look over elizza douchka
is looking like this my teacher's like
I'm like things are tough around here
for you huh you heard me nothing this
kid this kid I said things are tough on
you you got a listen in problem kid this
kid he's new he learned the
script word for word he's waiting for
you to say school he went like this he
grabbed his mic he went in
school and it just Echoes over the whole
[__] thing you stin right the [__]
whole place erupts in just belly
laughter I mean I'm my face I felt my
head get red and my ears got hot when I
get nervous my ears get hot sure I know
that and it just start and I started
sweating and I went in school I just
yelled at this kid that was my only
experience was there any with uh with
Eliza was there any interaction or just
like nice working with you you my
business she's always been nice I see
her now she goes to Boston Comics come
home that I do every year right and she
always goes with her husband and she's I
mean she's still ridiculous one of the
hottest human beings in the world but
we're kind of friendly now we we know
each other a little bit now she's I mean
she's just my
okay yeah now you're peers so you met a
child actor I I [__] up all my famous
people I know I [__] it up I [__] them
all up yeah CHR Chris Evans blocked me
right blocked you I remember that yeah
blocked me well what' you do well I
[__] it up I met him we became friends
and then I I texted him that
night I was like good
meeting remember when you were in
Captain America I [__] it up and then
I I repaired it schul help me repair it
and I repaired it and and I [__] it up
again and then recently on the bonfire
Jay made me [__] it up again I texted
him something I forget what I texted and
then and then uh it just blocked I
called and it was like you this number
can't be whatever and I was like [__]
what a boo that's awesome I'm terrible
I'm not I'm not good with famous people
I'm just not good you never text you
never they give me the number you never
use it I didn't know it was like Girls
We're Men I know but if you met a guy
you gave me your remember years ago I
didn't think I used it for four years
yeah I remember I remember you got mad
at him cuz he was still sending you
Twitter DMS and you're like [__] call
me you're like you have my number call
me I hate a text I'm not a fan of
texting I don't like it just call me
just call sure just call and say what's
Up's up phone calls and flat tvs do you
remember what do you remember I remember
that do you remember what that
conversation was about what we were
pitching him a y actually now that I
think about it when when before we
started pitching me yeah oh the skanks
pitch me too no [__] yeah they wanted
they were like we want to I was like
dude just go do your own thing you don't
want to be part of this oh okay yeah
we're PCT get on the network yeah yeah
yeah I I completely forgot about it
until that that well it's like at that
time it's like listen man you're gonna
leave anyways no I totally get you wear
wrong every show that I started left of
course every show that I started was
just as soon as things hopped up it's
like what are we doing here it is one of
those things of you do it on your own
it's a thing that you should be doing on
your own you did you you've always done
your own thing your own thing networks
were good when like uh all things comedy
did it because they kind of all stuck
together and huddled and then lifted
each other up but it it eventually you
know broke up sure you know what I mean
and that that happens with any network
got Chris Evans coming in [__] nine
camera Sho don't ruin it again it's a
nine camera shoot hey what's up man you
me Bobby and we got the flat tvs too you
got a bunch of flat tvs you can stay
here you got a you got a regular nerd
and a sexy nerd we do you got you got
the [__] spectrum of nerds we we got
T-Bone and new guy Luke yeah um all
right let's get into some [__]
patreon question with Bobby it's always
a good hang with that Bobby get what do
you need where's my bag can I get my bag
real quick your fanny pack it's not a
fanny pack it's a crossbody Louis
Vuitton is it real Louis Vuitton I
wanted to ask it came in I complimented
it but is it real come on I don't know
now what's that set you back well what's
that called that seems like a lot to me
four grand I got I got a Dicky jacket
1200 yeah it's over a th is L look it
yeah this is uh yeah this is pretty
expensive yeah some gum and some I know
what's in there I got gum it's stupid is
it regular gum or nicotine gum I can't
really hear also the the I just noticed
the the tattoo of your wife's name as
your as your wedding band yeah yikes I
had to do that you don't like Rings uh
no because I gain weight and lose it so
much over the I've gone through so many
I think I've gone through six holy [__]
dude he wears them as a necklace now
yeah dude there was points where it was
like I had to get it cut off [__] yeah I
was so fat it just was my finger was
purple so I had to get a and then get
another one and then I would lose weight
and then i' get lost in a pool what do
they do that did they cut that off at
the jewelry shop no the fire fire
department does draws of Life on that
bad boy I have an alarm at my
[Laughter]
house
um yeah they just they just uh I just
cut it off huh all right yeah it's uh
yeah I [__] hate the we but now she's
there forever there you go this actually
made her cry I I didn't my my wife's a
tough broad I'm pretty sure my wife
could take me if we were really fighting
sure I'm pretty sure she could take me
she'd do some she's a pretty tough chick
so you didn't tell her you not got a
tattoo got a tattoo of her name on my f
the trash romantic thing I've ever heard
in my life what that at your back free
skankfest you got that done at skank F
yeah baby did you tell her that yeah she
knows it was free yeah huh I told her
she's a nickel Chaser saving money
saving money they're good Bobby save
money I like it you don't have tattoos
right no nothing nothing I would get one
now but it just screams you know midlife
crisis a little bit really I know in my
heart of hearts how I would look at
myself at 18 if I was 37 balding and got
it that too why won't you get something
what would you get I would want to go
full sleeve I'd want to go all don't do
that that's why that yeah that's I
flabby arm I know that's i' have
to Joe Rogan I'd have to get chisel just
pizza and garlic knots all down his arm
it's his favorite foods a flat red freak
baby um all right let's get into it here
let's get a let's knock a couple of
questions out here um all right this
one's from the Kev Dev $10 homie never
had one read is a garbage if your buddy
comes over to your house to pregame then
Cuts their fingernails before leaving
for the night
you can't be doing that at someone
else's
house I mean you can't do that now are
you clipping or you biting I I I I I
despise biters you don't like biting I
would why would you bite your your
fingers touch you get you strike me as a
Manny guy I'm not a Manny guy but I've
gotten man's but I used to get manise
but then they those stupid bass that you
know you put your feet in at those
places oh they get bad I I got two dead
toenails because of that my big toes
both of them are [__] disgusting
my toe looks like Frito chips of that
couple of bugles on there I mean dude
cuz they have the they don't wash them
all the time I know yeah there was I
remember like a big six there was no
injury or anything like that it's
definitely from I got a fungi from those
things and that fungus the only way you
can get rid of it is if you take a pill
that could [__] your liver l or whatever
it's called I'm like I'm not doing that
that stuff's heavy I'm not going to die
because of a toenail that would suck you
guys would make fun of me forever what
is it is it black is it not black but it
actually fell off last year and uh now
it grew back a little better and since I
lost weight I think pressure on it when
I was 350 I don't think I was getting a
lot of blood down there so the healing
process you see fat people's shins when
they get like a little cut it lasts for
like nine years that's my biggest fear i
i i scrub my shins and I moisturize the
hell out of them I don't want to get fat
guy legs like that you don't have fat
you've never had fat guy legs which I
I'll tip my hat to you a lot of guys
smaller than you really got that fat guy
skin I have a little varicose veins and
I have a little bit of uh like from
getting hit when I was younger like the
the bruise doesn't go away I think
because of the circulation yeah so I'm
on top of that I got my aquafer all over
that I think I think that I the toenail
but now it's it's a little better now a
little better now yeah but cut so you're
sitting down once a week clipping or
like once every when you notice they
need it I keep Clippers everywhere you
got them in a bag I might I might I
might but I when I usually have a bag
I'll have a clipers but I have on my
keychain usually to too I have clippers
everywhere cuz I don't I forget it and
my wife is really she's one of those
where you know your fingernails she sees
dirty fingernails on dudes or long
fingernails she's [__] sure you got
to you got to run a tight chip she hates
it dirty fingernails are bad I have them
a lot yeah I I used to have them a lot I
try not to have you ever do like a post
on Instagram and you're holding
something and you're looking your
fingernails yeah it's [__] I hate it too
but will you clip anywhere I'll clip
anywhere but somebody's house that's
that's egregious I mean you can't do a
house you can't do a plane people do it
on the subway I had a buddy who would be
like I I cut my fingernails on the
subway that's disgusting [__] insane
that's disgusting people eating down
there a lot of people do a lot of people
do it you could you could do it on a
bench outside a bench yeah out outside a
bench cut your fingernails real quick I
usually try to do it like uh in the
house in the sink napkin grabb all the
fingernails in the toilet okay
I'll typically bite gentle put it behind
the couch bite yeah bite put it behind
the couch or I've said this I'll put it
in if I have like a empty coffee cup or
something I'll put it in there and then
throw it out did you say you bite and
then put it behind your couch yeah uhhuh
the best is you I'm a man Bobby let me
give you the perfect situ by my wife in
3 weeks cuz you're a Savage perfect
situation you got something in your
tooth and you have a little bit of a
long nail that's gross bite it 3/4 of
the way down pop it out clean that out
pop that out right behind the couch
it's on the verge of being a genius what
it's literally no it's too Army fingers
no that's science a magnifying glass
that's expect your fat
ass that's that's caveman science go
gadget
hogy salami sandwich pops out yeah
that's [__] insane to me I think
that's great I think the you figured
that out that's that's when I figured
out you could use your socks to wipe up
piss oh yeah oh what do you mean like
it's on just little when you pee on the
toilet late at night instead of having
to get the toilet and the the toilet
paper thing and it's not and they I just
sock it 100% you your suck if I do if I
miss that'll be that's tomorrow
morning's problem for me I'll go in and
take care of it in I'm I'm not cleaning
at 3:00 in the morning half sleeping
just take your foot up wipe away your
socks I don't sleep with socks I'm not a
[__] psychopath what if something
happens in the middle of the night
you're going to have [__] sock no
sock shoes you're going to you're going
to someone breaks in something happens a
[__] twister goes around you get some
traction a [__] twister comes through
your house what are the socks going to
do you're going to be able to [__]
have something on your feet yeah so you
don't get cuts and stuff on your
feet this is the thought process of a
formerly fat paranoid guy yeah 100% this
not the the sock will slow you down too
much you have a SE yeah that's four or
five minutes you could tornado wiped out
the whole neighborhood only one guy
survived how's that he was wearing his
socks yeah he's outside in his socks and
his feet aren't all cut up he's talking
to the news I'd like to thank
Haynes uh fingernails are amazing I
always get socks on my feet every night
in case something happens I'm in you're
N I don't know what that is something
happens dude somebody I mean if
something happens my feet can go in sh
somebody sneaks in the middle of the
night put shoes on
you woo woo your buddy was staring right
at me like I can't turn around listen
he's good he ain't that
good that was a he's one of the best but
he misses from time to time it was a
moment [__] it almost turned I thought
he started laughing at it and I was like
man Bobby's really giving on that that
one okay that felt good um I can't
believe you don't wear socks men wear
socks to bed no I think if we did a poll
no one wear socks socks get hot you ever
take them off in the middle of the night
do little your little piggies take them
off I like that I like getting in the
bed with socks and then taking them off
I mean no I keep I leave them on in case
something goes down them I got to I got
to take care of business don't
understand what does that mean what is
the difference of having socks and no
socks that you're that's going to imped
you okay I'm going to give you a
scenario and you tell me ready you're
lying in bed I'm laying in bed you what
you in your underwear you no shirt right
I'm in my undies undies you're in your
undies yeah that's it no socks no socks
tree falls crashes through the [__]
house okay Smashes in now the WEA
picture this Nock weather your house is
[__] up your girlfriend's dead no sack
the weather's coming was hail wind
wetness uhhuh and you got to go save
your wife get the dog out the kid you
got to go get everybody out of this
place what what are you going to do
first you just going to do it with no
sock you're going to put nothing on your
feet what's the socks aren't helping me
unless I'm wearing waterproof socks 100%
helping
you% then I got wet I'm standing outside
waiting for the fire department with wet
socks like assho going to catch a cold
with with next thing you know you're
sick I'm in my underwear n dude you got
some form of protection over your feet
so you'd rather have nothing on Fe kind
of socks are you wearing
dude seal skin socks you'd have nothing
on your feet you'd have rather have
nothing on your feet at all yes and be
out in the snow and the cold and the wet
how long do you think socks are going to
keep I live on the sixth floor if I end
up in the snow we got bigger problems
Bobby I mean that's yeah you know what
they say I like the picture you crashes
through the house you know what they say
to each his own sure sure is on is on I
I hope something happens and you were
like [__] I wish I had socks it's going
to happen I'm going be cursing that yeah
Bobby plan's going down Bobby's putting
his socks on I don't know what's going
to happen to you guys but I'm going be
all right jumps out so he can run uh
slides right down the aisle I hope you
get
kidnapped and then you but then you get
out and you have no socks and you're in
the desert and your feet are like ow oo
ow but you're like [__] I wish I had my
socks are not going to help that a
little bit if you got to walk through
listen yes if if set of circumstances
arises where I have end up in the desert
and I have to walk to safety I might
need a pair of socks so the situation is
if a tree crashes through the house you
get kidnapped you get brought to the
desert you want to have a pair of socks
on I'll give you that a lot of [__] up
so when you go to bed tonight you go B I
also think you might need to change
neighborhoods if you think that's going
to happen to you I you got you got to
move into a more secure I go to bed at
my undies and I always tell if something
happens this is the way this is this is
how I'm I'm I'm squaring off or I'm
going out or I'm doing whatever yeah way
the Mandalorian yeah this is the way
you're out my good Fell's bbds my
tidies uh all right let's see this one's
from Sam Adams if you enter a business
this is more of a a a discussion if you
enter a business where you have to stand
in line say like the dry cleaner or
whatever and uh where you get this code
cleaned by the way where I should get
this code cleaned uh person before you
holds the door for you mhm let you in
yeah do you then give them your spot in
line or do you stand in line in front of
them oo this is a good you I mean like
they hold the door so you enter you're
both walking converging on the dry
cleaner at the same time they open the
door for you let you in yeah now you're
in line in front of them that they
allowed or that you go you could but you
don't have to what I'm what I'm doing
when I hold that door for you is I'm
giving you that spot I am saying I
respect that this is I'm going to let
you take I'm in Rush buddy in no rush
guys do your thing have at it have at it
you gave me that spot okay so you don't
have to you could but here's what you
run the risk of here's what you run the
risk of hey oh you go no no no you go no
you sure you go now you're in that now
it's a little weird now you're like I
did a good thing I put my did I was nice
all you had to do is take it say thank
you and I feel good and you feel good
that this somebody good out there and if
now we're fighting we're having a micro
fight over niess which is one of the I
hate micro nice fights you're not wrong
on that it's terrible that's very that's
a very good assumption you're giving
them that spot when you open the door
don't [__] with somebody's Karma I would
say the gentleman move is they let they
open the door let you in thank you I
know you you you go ahead offer once
just once you want to go no because then
if they take it you're like ah what a
[__] prick I see yeah I see offer
sucker [__] scumbag I think we think
the the generosity is coming in the
store the generosity is not coming in
this so for you the generosity is I'm
giving I'm giving you the spot before we
even get in there just take what if you
didn't know there was a line in there
though and you're like ah [__] hey no
that that's the risk you take how many
times you go you park and you see
somebody else Park and then you both and
all of a sudden they speed and now
you're speeding and then this you know
what I mean and you get that thing
that's such a suck thing that you have
to deal with in society but there's
nothing better when somebody just hey go
ahead and you're like thanks man and you
go in and you get in the line and
they're behind you and there's no
pressure there's no anxiety there's no
that's the way we all should live I
that's very profound honestly that's
yeah that's gr I I didn't think of it
that way cuz there's been so many times
I've gotten into that back and forth of
kindness or whatever and then it's like
you want to kind of just win and then if
you're standing in front you're in your
head of like this [__] guy's probably
sitting behind me going this [__] fat
ass took my spot blah blah blah can't do
it all unneeded if because I've been on
the other side where I'll I'll usually
when I see somebody coming I let them go
because I get that I got to go I same
and I'm like you know I'm like all right
[__] it here you go go ahead just go
ahead M you know what I mean oh thank
you very much you're welcome no problem
and then I get right in bang what if you
hold the door and you don't get a thank
you not the this the line thing but just
in general oh then I'll cut their
child you better be wearing socks buddy
Fu it's about to turn dor for you I'll
piss down his
skull man nothing gets me hotter than
[__] not getting to thank you dude I
you know what you know what [__]
really makes me mad when I don't get
you're
welcome you're welcome when they just do
it and I go thank you very much and they
just stare at me really say you're
welcome oh that's real crazy all right
watch this watch this ready yeah you're
coming in I hold the door oh thanks
man I'm not standing there looking at
you I'm moving through n of course for
sure there's a there's a part of this
piece missing you [__] H he's not wrong
there's a thank you and there's your
welcome it is almost a little
condescending yeah go ahead yeah it's
like what did you do it cuz you're a
[__] face did you we we're exchanging
gifts right now and it's called
pleasantries so I'm going to do this so
you go thank you you're and I'm going to
go you're welcome you're not wrong and
then Society can move on okay then we
get to
live then we all go home and see family
cuz if you don't say you're welcome I
will kill you I you know we're all
having Cruise turkey on Thanksgiving
look at I hate that I hate to know thank
you it sucks [__] you but to know you're
welcome it's kind of like like you're
better than you're better than me uhhuh
you did this for peasants yes yes you're
a good peasant go that's also in our
heads but sure yeah I like I like that
level of crazy body yeah know you're
right there you know what I hate I live
my my building is two door like you know
just like the little vestibule type
thing so if so we're both convert you
know we get off the elevators we're
walking the first guy or person to the
door holds the door if typically if it's
two dudes holds the first door and I go
oh thank you now I got to get the second
door for him and I do and we do it but
it does seem so kind of for oh thank you
no after you thank you and it just seems
very fake well it's not fake it's it's a
little fake the double door makes the
whole Rhythm of the thank you you're
welcome show you how did your parents do
a good job and I do it I have to do it I
I have always prided myself on my
manners I tell my son a little I tell my
son all the time when somebody will hold
the door and then if the other person
doesn't they just go in I'll be like
that that person doesn't have good
parents yeah we've I've set that's a
broken home and you slam it in their
face you follow them home how about when
you [__] hold the
door and then thank you very much thank
you very much thank you and then they
just keep coming yeah you're there's
usually a
yeah you're door all and those stank you
dry up after like the second or third
person they think you're working there
yeah that's the worst and I I usually
look like I work a lot of those
plac face me too the double door thing
is bad you open the one door and they
come in and they go in the other one I'm
standing right here I [__] work for
talk about feeling like a real loser we
immediately get mad at that slight trans
it's like that thing I I i' I've told
you this when you offer somebody to like
if people are trying to take a selfie
hey you want me to take that for you and
they're like no you feel like a real Lo
that pig I don't want to take your
picture anyway and they go oh they'll go
like this [__] you I got it I know we
have it it's like all right go f think
I'm steal your phone yeah have you ever
done that stolen somebody's phone no no
no just take it and go okay and then run
and then go I'm kidding I've done that
that's fun just run cuz their faces are
this shock I would trip or something
like that
scorpioning yourself I wasn't really
steal I swear to God I'm a
comedian uh it's a cool for call an
ambulance on
this you fall and break your jaw you
can't even explain
yourself trying to show trying to show
him the podcast I
swear uh I've always said you can learn
a lot uh in a WWA parking lot of who the
the the common courtesy in a w
specifically Philadelphia surrounding
area Wawa parking lot fight will happen
if you don't that common cursy is so
extended because they know you'll get
the yeah you're [__]
welcome they're looking for it they're
high strung it's like and you that's it
could be the the worst kind of person
the best kind of everybody says please
and thank you and you're welcome holding
door to W it's like we're driving down
the street on the highway and it always
fascinates me there's so many cars so
many different and none of us Mo for the
most part we're not just smashing into
each other time I could just go I could
ruin everyone's day right now what the
[__] I didn't know that you psycho but I
don't but you don't why because of I got
a gig to do I got the Pod because
there's rules Unwritten [__] rules
dude are you a uh are you a loer
vehicular hand manslaughter is well
documented no it's not you can kill
people you can just say it's an accident
you can be like I they don't see your
face in the car going [__] me they're
not up here oh they're only out there
Jesus I meant to do it that's that's a
great
line they're not up here they they don't
know what's going on Jesus they're in
the back of an ambulance right now
you're not driving the rent cars anymore
I'll tell you that that's why you have
disposable
jackets shave my head real quick tie my
beard I saw the whole thing
uh all we got time for one or two more
then we got a wrap her up here uh this
one Speaking of jacuzzi this one's from
uh Brum Kenyon $10 homie never had one
righted is a garbage if my girlfriend
goes to 24-Hour Fitness just to use the
jacuzzi she's
cheating you idiot you idiot holy
[__] you dude what the it's man 101
where you going use the jacuzzi at
what 2:30 in the morning yeah you're
walking funny holy [__] if your husband
does it he's gay wait what what has a
Jacuzzi
24hour I don't think 24-hour fitnesses
have Jacuzzi they don't she's blowing a
guy in a parking lot of a Boston
Market [__] idiot which R are you
that's nuts dude that's great put the
kai bash on
that yeah man you got to put an apple
tag on that chick air tagger you just
see it moving back and forth real quick
we got to air tag that chick man she's
she's she's blowing somebody oh man all
right we got to wrap it up on that
that's [__] amazing I didn't think of
that at all gang Mr Robert Kelly
legendary comedian best and ab check out
the pods you got bone to pick with Mr
Paul ver you got the regs with Lis J
Gomez you got Joe L you got Dan Soder
you got of course the bonfire Mr oerson
to much too much and you got of course
the legendary you know what dude check
it out Bobby Kelly anything else you
want the folks I didn't know dates
website whatever what's cooking uh just
go to my website Robert kelly.com or go
go to punch up. live go to punch-up to
[__] everything else go to punch up.
live my special is up there for free
killbox uh and all my dates are up there
you can buy tickets up on punch up. live
it's a brand new uh site for Comedians
and uh I'm totally digging it so go
there check me out for all my dates come
see me live and uh you know all my other
[__] that I'm doing you guys got to come
on uh bone to pick man let's do it baby
love it one of the absolute best Mr
Robert Kelly what do you got for him uh
guys we are getting ready to announce
our 202 for tour so let us know where we
should go there's a link in the
description of this episode let us know
what cities to go to the only tickets
are on sale right now are town hall on
May 9th New York City get those [__]
tickets now it's going to sell out also
the a card gam is available at AR
garbage.com yeah gang we love you and
we'll see you next week peace peace